the volume of a box is 405 cube units or
gets cubic units so they just want to
keep it general it could have been in
cubic feet or cubic meters or cubic
centimeters or cubic miles who knows
they just want to keep it as units keep
it as general as possible the length is
X units the width is X plus 4 units and
the height is 9 units let me draw this
box here so let me draw this box so
let's let me draw a little box here so
we have a nice little visualization so
they tell us that the length is X maybe
we could call it well it's called this
the length right there they say the
width is X plus 4 the width is X plus 4
and the height is 9 of this box in units
what are the dimensions of the box well
they also tell us that the volume is 405
so the volume 405 let me do it this way
so if we wanted to calculate the volume
over to be well it would be the width it
would be X plus 4 times the length times
X times 9 times 9 that's literally the
volume of the box now they also tell us
that the volume of the box is 405 cubic
units is equal to 405 so now we just
solve for X so what do we get here if we
distribute this X into this X plus 4
actually if we distribute a 9 X let me
just rewrite it this is the same thing
as 9 x times X plus 4 is equal to 405 9
x times X is equal to 9 x squared 9 X
times 4 is equal to 36 X is equal to 405
now we want our quadratic expression to
be equal to 0 so let's subtract let's
subtract 45 405 from both sides of this
equation so when you do that your right
hand side equals 0 and your left hand
side is 9 x squared plus 36 X minus 405
now is there any common factor to the
these numbers right here well let's see
405 four plus zero plus five is nine so
that is divisible by nine so all of
these are divisible by nine let's just
let's just figure out what 405 divided
by nine is so nine goes into 405 nine
goes into forty four times four times
nine is thirty-six subtract you get 45
nine goes into 45 five times five times
nine is forty-five subtract you get zero
so it goes forty five times so if we
factor out a 9 here we get nine times x
squared actually even better you don't
even have to factor out a 9 to think
about it you can divide both sides of
this equation by nine so if you can
divide all of the terms by nine it won't
change the equation you're doing the
same thing to both sides of the equation
which we've learned long ago is a very
valid thing to do so here you get x
squared if you if you just had this
expression here and someone were told
you to factor it then you would have to
factor out the nine but because this is
an equation it equals zero let's just
divide everything by nine it'll simplify
things so you get x squared plus 4x
minus 45 is equal to zero and now we can
try to factor this right here and this
is this fits the pattern where we don't
have a leading one out here so we don't
even have to do it by grouping you just
have to think what two numbers when I
take their product I get negative 45 and
when I take their sum I get positive 4
therefore apart one has to be positive
one has to be negative they're positive
versions have to be for Part B when you
take the sum you're really taking their
difference because one of them is
negative so let's think about it well if
you have positive nine and negative five
I think that'll work right positive nine
plus negative five is four and when you
take the product you get negative 45 so
you have X plus nine times X minus five
is equal to zero just factored it out
and then we've seen this before if you
have two numbers when you take their
product that equals zero that means one
of these numbers at least has to be
equal to 0 so X so this means that X
plus
nine is equal to zero let me scroll down
a little bit
X plus nine is equal to zero or X minus
five is equal to zero so if we subtract
nine from this equation right there you
get X is equal to negative nine or if
you add five to both sides of this
equation here you get X is equal to five
so these are both possible values of X
right here so the box if you take X is
equal to negative nine well X equal to
negative nine won't work because if you
put negative nine here you're going to
have a you're going to have a box that
has a width of negative five a length of
negative nine and a height of nine and
if we're talking about our reality we
don't have negative distances like this
that can't be the length or the width so
x equals negative nine isn't appropriate
for this problem because in this problem
we need to have positive dimensions so
let's see for what happens with x equals
five x equals five x plus four is nine
and this dimension right here is going
to be five and that seems pretty
reasonable for our reality and let's
verify that this does end up with the
volume of 405 nine times five is forty
five times nine is indeed 405 we just
figure that out over here that 45 that
45 times nine is 405 so we're done